there's this amazing picture of my
co-worker it's him reading a ninja
turtles book lying next to a super
soaker
when the super soaker came out it was a
game changer the slogan wetter is better
was essentially a mantra for kids during
summer break
so when i went to atlanta to interview
the guy responsible for all that i had
to show him the photo
that's funny
lonnie johnson invented the super soaker
back in 1982
but that is not his only invention
well i have over 100 patents
everything from the nerf gun to a
thermoelectric energy converter he also
worked on nasa's galileo mission to
jupiter and alongside the us military
the first super soaker actually i made
in my shop in my basement in the
evenings when i would come home from
work and at the time i was actually
working on the stealth department
program back when it was highly
classified and i actually couldn't even
tell my wife what i was working on
during the daytime it was that that top
secret the original name for the super
soaker was the drencher we ran into a
challenge uh regarding the name because
another
inventor claimed it so we changed the
name to super soaker just to avoid
having to to deal with that super soaker
is definitely a way better name
when he started lonnie wasn't trying to
create a toy for kids i was working on a
new type of heat pump that would use
water as a working fluid instead of
freon
and i was experimenting with some
nozzles that i had machined
and i shot a stream of water across the
bathroom and i thought she's maybe i
should put this hard side stuff aside
and work on something fun like a water
gun
it still works and this brings me back
to a previous point monty johnson is a
super genius scientist
this is his lab
and this is what he's working on now
right now i'm working on advanced
maverick technology my goal is to
develop a battery that will store about
three times the energy of a lithium ion
battery in comparison the super soaker
might not seem as hard science
but it was still a really really
important invention